en fait sur la dernière vidéo il y avait
pas un problème parce que ça me semble
un peu terre de couleurs des armées
couleurs ont la tâche de régler ça parle
bon alors c'est fini
ok c'est bon c'est parfait comme ça
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
salut tout le monde alors cette semaine
une vidéo sur un jeu auquel j'aurais
jamais cru jouer un jour très
franchement je veux dire car je suis
passé devant jeu je me suis dit mais mes
pairs mais ça existe ce truc là
alors donc je vais prises pour ne pas
mourir idiot
vous savez les jeux vidéo sont souvent
considérés depuis toujours comme étant
des jeux pour garçons mais les jeux pour
filles c'était rare mais ça existait
aussi un et ça existait bien avant que
les filles se mettent à avoir notre
crainte ou alors qu'on découvre qu'il
suffisait de coller une fille devant les
signes pour avoir la paix maintenant si
on remonte 20 ans en arrière on trouve
finalement assez peu de références
confie faut dire que pendant que nous
les mecs on reste à la maison pour se
faire chier essayé de passer le niveau
aquatique sur tortues ninja les filles
elles sortaient pour parler et voir des
vrais gens je sais qu une fille quand
même mais bon malgré ça les éditeurs de
jeux vidéo avec quand même tenté de
produire de jeu pour filles dans
l'espoir d' exploiter ces 50% de joueurs
potentiels et parmi ces jeux du négroïde
bien connu une [ __ ] en plastique et
eu droit ces adaptations sur toutes les
consoles
je parle évidemment de barbie allons-y
pour barbie sorti en 1992 en europe et
allons commencer ce test dernière chose
moi je veux gagner je m'engage à ne pas
faire plus de 9 la misogynie
pendant toute cette vidéo
ouais c'est parti ce jeu est développé
dans par générique nick déjà vous voyez
la pauvre barbie on voit qu'elle a été
gravement brûlé au visage
l'ensemble du corps d'ailleurs alors
qu'une version zombie de barbie je sais
pas donc nous y voilà pour l'intro est
là whaou
[ __ ] barbie siens livre arbitres
elle livre dans ses mains ça
impliquerait ça pourrait vouloir dire qu
éventuellement elle sait lire mais mais
mais mais ce jeu ce jeu se révèle déjà
être plein de surprises
c'est incroyable allez bien commencer
quelque part
pauvre darby je suis vraiment trop
fatigué pour lui et me coucher en j'ai
plein de trucs à faire demain tu
imaginais pas le cas
et puis faut aussi que je passe 11 ans
et 10 pour chercher les alors qu'ils me
permets de rien branler de la journée
[Musique]
donc ça a l'air d'être un jeu de plates
formes classiques en moulant fortes sont
au même que je sais bien pour que barbie
est anorexique mais là quand même et des
fils d'odin pesanteur donc le but est
simplement d'arriver au bout des dix
mots avec comme seule arme des boîtes de
tampon que barbie peut jeter comme ça
les fuites et dont il faut doser la
puissance en restant plus ou moins
longtemps appuyé sur le bouton b ça
c'est un des bras des tampons cd besoin
de vous pour animaux bontemps
basculement messieurs l'enjeu des boîtes
debout pour animaux séquelles encore
plus comme que je croyais enfin quoi
c'est pas macho dire qu'elle est conne
quand je veux dire quand tu ne la bouffe
un bon choix mais comment toi tu j'ai la
boite de concret sur la tronche mais je
veux dire c'est vrai quoi d'arbitré
connaît restait qu'à voir des animaux
avait pas s'empêcher l'eau rejetée être
qu'à la gueule pour les faire bouger
enfin moi je dis ça mais en fait c'est
plus facile à dire qu'à faire un bus
vous pouvez pas tiré droit avec vos
tampon broken je sais pas il faut
essayer donc de choper le coup avec la
trajectoire et la puissance de votre
cher ça ressemble toit de la péta encore
fait
donc évidemment au fil du jeu vous
pourrez ramasser des objets qui vous
redonneront de l'énergie ou des points
qui seront comptabilisés à la fin de
chaque niveau si vous avez envie de
comparer vos high score à mardi
du moins si vous avez vraiment rien
d'autre à [ __ ] alors évidemment ce jeu
sera plein de chaleur il faudra éviter
les raquettes de tennis
les cerfs volants tueurs les valeurs de
plage les torchons les sombreros et tout
un tas d'autres g mais heureusement les
petits animaux de barbie tels que les
chiens les plus quand les hamburgers et
les chats seront là pour vous aider dans
votre mission au travers des différents
niveaux tellement magnifique couvert de
tellement de rose que ça vous donnera
envie de chier d arc en ciel
d'ailleurs en premier abord on pourrait
croire que ce jeu serait assez facile
puisque normalement il est réservé à des
filles mais en fait non on alterne des
passages qui sont ridiculement facile
avec d'autres qui sont finalement quand
même assez costaud le niveau 3 par
exemple comme les deux premiers niveaux
se passe dans un magasin évidemment
c'est parce qu'ils vendent mais c'est
sûrement pas leur cycle au pays la
hausse en tout cas est donc ce magasin
rempli deux gouttes d'eau de jets d'eau
et de saumon de norvège comprendre il
faut bien mémorisé l'endroit où les sons
mots sortent pour passer les manger
essayer de passer rapidement ce qui
n'est pas évident vu comment barbie
avancent et sont d'ailleurs au niveau
des sauts je sais pas si l'espèce de son
compte en tout le temps quand on saute
est là pour faire croire que barbie fait
des sauts agile et gracieux mais en tout
cas ça devient casse-couilles super
rapidement ce passage-là fait partie des
deux trois sont pas évidents dans le jeu
ah oui on peut pas dire qu'il est
vraiment dur mais les décors se
ressemblent tellement en fait que ça
offre aucun élément pour se repérer du
coup barbie se mange tellement de
poissons qui risquerait presque donc
devenir intelligent
remarque c'est pas plus mal comme ça va
peut-être se rendre compte qu est un
marché sur le sol juste en dessous non
content c'est un rêve blondin faut pas
trop demander
ab sérieux avaient franchement mourir à
cause d'un poisson pour une morue c'est
vraiment un comble il coûte pour deux
cela c'est quoi ce délire est lui aussi
attend c'est que c'est quoi ce qu'ils
voient avec toute cette flore très
sérieux pour point le rêve d'un couloir
avec des fontaines sur 3 km même quand
tu finis le niveau les rêves d'une
fontaine géante
elle a envie de pisé c'est pas possible
on peut dire qu'elle fait des revues min
moi c'est celui qui a dit ça et puis
aussi à franchement ce niveau serait pas
aussi chiant si barbie pouvez simplement
se mettre à quatre pattes quand vous
mourrez barbie est confronté à un
terrible choix
se réveiller ou se rendormir quelle vie
palpitante
bon bah oui mais moi je choisis je me
réveille de toute façon dû les yeux
dilater que barbie à ça m'étonne pas
trop qu'elle fasse des rêves seul ou à
vrai dire assez fantastique en masse en
revient au début je pensais que se
réveiller ça donnerait en un accès à
d'autres niveaux tu serait réveillé mais
en fait trop ça correspond dans la game
over tout simplement
en fait ça correspond un simple choix
continu ou kit mais bon ça ne devait pas
faire à ses filles alors ça a été écrit
comme ça
globalement mises à part quelques phases
de plates formes assez chiante surtout à
cause de leur longueur le jeu se finit
assez vite d'ailleurs tiens détail idiot
de ce jeu dans le niveau sous marin la
hitbox de barbie c'est à dire l'endroit
avec lequel elle ramasse des objets ou
prendre des coups c'est son cul je
prends soin pour bien montrer à quel
point ce jeu a été fait à l'arraché par
exemple regardez cet item que je vais
vraiment que je me ramasse et je suis
obligé d'attendre que l'item atteignent
les fesses de barbie pour pouvoir le
ramasser et avec les ennemis c'est
pareil ils me font ils me font rire nous
touche pas à moi de les prendre
pendant q2 maman autant comment tu veux
dire autrement sinon donc à la fin de
chaque niveau va croiser des cauchemars
de barbie qui seront des genres de
bosses ou air et je déconne pas il ya
vraiment des bosses dans barbie il
faudra faire 10 parce que je sais c'est
pour l'ambiance
bon il faudra faire disparaître les
terribles fantôme de fringants soldes
les cruelles four à pizzas et les
démoniaques glace en boule qui font
grossir mardi est donc une fois que vous
aurez fini le boss de fin
c'est bon on a compris et vous aurez
donc droit à la superbe cinématique de
fin ou barbie va enfin chercher ce qui
lui manque le plus dans sa vie le rêve
de toutes les pistes une terre de talent
évidemment je sais que je pour filles
mais là c'est vraiment trop que je veux
dire est ce que tout a besoin d'être
aussi rose est aussi nié je ne demande
pas barbie de rêver de devenir
biochimiste mais là c'est carrément
réducteur de voir que le seul objectif
de barbie dans la vie c'est de récupérer
une paire de talons euros
ils ont dû se dire bros jeux pour filles
a pas besoin de faire des efforts sauf
qu'en même temps et jeux pour filles ou
pas les cartouches savez les carènes
entre 350 et 500 balles à l'époque
et puis bon au passage à était censée
retrouver qu'elle a une fête mais bon vu
qu'à la fin du jeu et rêve encore je
crois que ce pauvre kanye risque
d'attendre longtemps
[Musique]
bon cela dit ouais ce jeu avait la
décence de t'occuper quelques temps vu
qu'ils avaient quand même des passages
qui était pas évident mais les autres
jeux barbie en général ils étaient
complètement dénué d'intérêt tellement
c'était facile barbie super modèle qui
nous régale d'une multitude de mini jeux
de mémoire entrecoupés de formidable
séquence où barbie a décidé de faire
chier les gens
elle les fait chier en ligne avec un jeu
de mémoire
bon alors le cheveu c'est sa boucle
d'oreille ouais je m'en fout en fait un
geste vers la plage mais ils ont fait
tomber mardi
petit détour par les podiums on constate
toute la grâce et l'élégance des
mouvements de sumo de barbie voilà donc
si le nôtre au bout a déjà vu un
mannequin faire ce genre de mouvement
dans un défilé qui me le dise chez
corinne le bois et ainsi de suite que ce
soit en vélo ou à la montagne on
alternera donc les phases de jeu de
mémoire et des phases de jeu de rien du
tout où on fait rien à part
avancer autant avec barbie sur nes on
avait un jeu avec une difficulté adapté
pour filles autant avec barbie sur
megadrive on a un jeu avec une
difficulté adapté pour coiro ils sont
pas fatigués il ya que trois mini-jeux
différents ils auraient quand même pu en
rajouter d'autres en rapport avec
l'univers chic et glamour des mannequins
- c'est pas mal la bonne idée la sas et
à creuser
bref quand on voit des jeux comme ça on
comprend pourquoi les éditeurs ont
jamais réussi à mettre un public féminin
aux jeux vidéo mais pourtant un jour la
nintendo ds est arrivé avec des oeuvres
d'art pour filles comme les impatients
mariage de rêve léa passion mes secrets
de filles léa passion mystère au lycée
et enfin bref je mets d'ailleurs
regardez voilà la vidéo est fini et j'ai
toujours un point j'ai tenu ma promesse
j'ai pas fait plus de 9 la veille macho
pendant tout ce test voilà bien sûr feu
et mais rangé sa ba sa place jeux pour
filles dans la cuisine
[Musique]
g